if you're in the humanities the world is
running under your feet your life is
um created by the science to technology
by the stem science technology
engineering and either math or medicine
and then on the scientist's side you
know they could be they could feel oh my
gosh you know the peoples think that
we're nerds or that we're dry people or
that we only see things as numbers as if
it isn't beautiful when you've got an
equation that works I mean they people
don't understand this and so it's a lack
of understanding on each side but
since I've been a science fiction writer
my whole life I've been trying to say
science is actually quite modest in that
it doesn't want to tell people what to
do or what things mean so science
scientists doing their science well will
be quite they won't claim more for
science than it is attempting right it's
just to explain things and once you if
you clarify that to people in the
humanities and they get over this notion
that oh scientists have taken over the
world and they and when actually they
haven't they just have
provided an amazingly powerful tools
right any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
Magic
[Music]
welcome everybody to what promises to be
an out of this world adventure with a
HomeTown hero a favorite son
of UCSD and California in general but
really of of Earth and Mars Fame and
that's Kim Stanley Robinson Stan as we
know him here renowned science fiction
author but also non-fiction author and
today we're talking about two of his
books that I've had an incredible impact
on me and uh just my thought process
including my hero Galileo Galilei who uh
was really the last time we were
together for an official event of any
kind was in 2012 I think it was uh maybe
it was 2014. and I was commemorating the
400th anniversary of Galileo or the
400th anniversary of the telescope I
believe it was we'll put some b-roll and
we'll show that here yeah so you and I
and Mario bajajoli who's a professor now
he's at uh UCLA he was at Davis at the
time where you spend a lot of time and
we did at a birthday party for Galileo
uh and in the back of my mind it was in
February which Galileo's birthday is the
day after Valentine's Day February 15th
and I knew that a month later we'd be
announcing to the great Fanfare that we
discovered waves of gravity percolating
through the universe courtesy of a
refracting telescope just like the one
that Galileo utilized to peer into the
heavens but I couldn't make that note so
I was keeping a deep secret while we
were speaking but we did a wonderful
event together and you're back on campus
to do more events you've been so
prolific we're going to talk about
Galileo's dream which really is you know
probably my favorite science fiction
book fantasy fan fiction I don't know
how you think of it but that's the way I
think about it
um 20 hours of goodness that I've
listened to multiple times and we're
also going to be talking about something
that's also near and dear to my heart
which is uh which is the subject of your
latest book which is uh about the Sierra
Nevada mountain range which is not far
from here and I didn't realize how much
time you spent there including time when
you're spending time here so first of
all Stan welcome to UCSD welcome back
welcome home uh we love having you here
and you're so gracious with your time to
to spend some time with us we have
questions from the audience we have
questions from me and and so for but
first of all I wanted to ask you what
drove you you know I mean predominantly
you're known as science fiction writer
of the highest magnitude Hugo nebula all
the awards he could win right
um what tribute to write a non-fiction
book about the Sierra Nevada mountain
range
well I I've wanted to for decades but I
am a science fiction novelist and I had
um novels to write contracts to fulfill
so it kind of just sat there in the back
of my mind and it was also um
something to think about when I was
hiking because hiking is an all-day
thing the hours pass you got time to
think it is um
you it's a double Consciousness maybe I
mean it's a space that
demands your attention and gets your
attention it's a beautiful space to walk
in the High Sierra but also there's time
especially on trail to ponder you know
how would you write this down in
sentences which is something that always
comes to me
to me and I gotta say
um before I forget thank you so much for
mentioning Galileo's dream it's one of
my favorite of my own novels I love it
because I love Galileo and that was an
opportunity and it since then I've been
on a roll
um partly contractual partly life
situation partly a wonderful editor Tim
Holman who platformed me
and that's now seven novels back and it
it's um I think it's a little lost in
the shuffle of my career compared to my
other novels since and the people who
like Galileo or think of it as a
historical novel well it's got some
pretty weird chapters the people who
think of it as a science fiction novel
there's an awful lot of detail about
Galileo's people and quantum
entanglement and his life in in Florence
and Pisa and in Rome so if you're a
science fiction fan it's too historical
if you're a historical fan is too
science fictional so maybe that's one
explanation for it or just who you never
know but I'm very happy that you like
that book because I like it a lot too
because he here's what he taught me I
was feeling low I was feeling thrashed I
had finished a novel a Trilogy set in
Washington DC and then had kicked my ass
and I was thinking maybe I'm done and
then I started working on Galileo I
moved and started writing Outdoors that
was important but more important was
Galileo I realized that guy
he went through a lot of hard stuff
physical ailments including going blind
um the pope putting him under house
arrest and almost burning him at the
stake his daughter died young when he
was still alive these are
um
this is that's as difficult as life gets
in terms of throwing hard things at you
and all he did was work more he just
worked harder and um they his famous
book the DIA logo is um
um uh justly famous but the one he wrote
at the end of his life the best course
the discourse yeah is amazing and simply
amazing and and so you know everything
that he ever thought for 40 years put
into one book
and at that point I felt a little
embarrassed for myself or a little
ashamed of myself thinking you know you
think you have it hard so just start
working and I started working and I
realized he had the secret that actually
my low point was basically probably from
spending too much time indoors and
getting bored with sitting at a laptop
indoors when I moved outdoors I was
enjoying riding again I had the good
editor so Galileo taught me some really
important lessons and and people don't
really realize so I had the honor to
because of the University of California
press owns the rights to the definitive
translation by Stillman Drake of the
dialogue I had the honor of Performing
and creating the very first audiobook
ever by Galileo which is the dialogue
read by uh my friend Carlo ravelli and
another friend Italian Friend Lucio
piccharillo so we play it in actual
performance so we act it out in this
audiobook which one were you uh so I was
uh I am totally you were simplistic no
no no my friend Carlo is of course
alviati yeah I am a segreto and then
there's simplicio the the Pope's
character feudally but the thing that
kind of does remind me of of of Galileo
when I read your writing is there's a
poetry there are sections of Galileo's
dream where you describe there's not a
spoiler I don't think you can spoil it
correct me from can you spoil a book
that's 12 years old or whatever no no
talking your very last page could be
discussed so but which I won't but their
passages where you describe Galileo
visiting the moons of of Jupiter and you
describe the rich ochres the Tans the
purples and it's a page but it's it's
rapturous and I listen to the I love
hearing your voice and The Narrative of
that book is a is a wonderful narrator I
wish I could have gotten him for some of
my books uh instead of me but but when
you have this eye it reminds me of
Galileo there are passages in the
dialogue which are the deepest poetry he
speaks at sometimes and he's of course
speaking with some false humility
because he had a healthy ego as I want
to get into as a great scientist great
writer I think you need a little bit of
a Swagger to do good to do greatness and
balance that with humility but he said
in the final passage he said I have not
meant to travel roads never trodden but
merely to open a portal to Vistas such
that other Travelers much more
perspicacious than me will be able to
unveil Secrets which I can only dimly
grasp but he has just this beautiful way
of writing evocative he talks about the
sun with all those planets revolving
independent upon of course that's what
he was trying to prove which he didn't
successfully do in that book but he says
still finds time to ripen a bunch of
grapes on the vine it's just it's just
amazing and I think about your writing
in this new book
about the High Sierras you have this
this this real poetic sense of attention
to detail which I'm wondering is that
born of a scientific curiosity not
unlike Galileo's where does that come
from the attention to detail that you're
known for
well
I wonder
certainly most of the scientists I've
known
they're fascinated by what they're
studying so it's not just a job it's a
form of devotional practice in other
words you're you're the the pain of
attention is a kind of a worship of
reality and Galileo was very much in
that mode the the world was kind of a
miracle to him filled with Mysteries and
some of his theories were wrong I mean
the tides vexed him without gravity
without calculus he was
constantly at the edge of his own
understanding and super curious so he's
paying attention and throwing theories
out there and he was a beautiful stylist
his I'm told by Mario since I don't read
Italian but that you know along with a
Machiavelli and Dante they sort of
turned the Florence the Florentine
um uh dialect into classical Italian
High Italian because of their powers as
writers that just became the norm for
written Italian when there were so many
dialects at the time
well it makes sense to me reading him in
English he's Vivid he cuts to the chase
there was a tradition in his time of
debase after dinner you know because it
was a patronage system and you were
entertaining the duke or the
medicis or the any or the or the the the
elected well
yeah in Venice so two people would go at
it and have a debate and a God you would
have lost it got loud
exactly he did have a healthy ego
because he knew he was smarter than
almost anybody alive in his time and I
had such pleasure throwing him into
weird situations you know like the the
years
but but going into the year 3000 if you
threw that at Galileo he would be doing
his best to comprehend it and when in
one of my future characters says to him
you know well you know of course you
can't know everything
um that there is to know and he's like
why not I I know everything there's you
know in my time how has the year 3000
any different and
um a thorough going pleasure to
contemplate and Mario biagioli kept
telling me do not romanticize this guy
he was a real son of a he was uh
he was a schemer and a grasper there was
no such thing as intellectual property
rights he had to fight and scheme and I
mean he he had uh he wasn't unscrupulous
by by any means he had Scruples and and
values but but he was had to be tough
yeah Mario points out he concealed how
the telescope was perfected by him not
invented it was a form of you know
property and then trademark investment
for his own safety as you point out he
had all these people depended on him
right yeah that's right and he and when
he had his that first book about the
Moon published he put the actual
statistics last in a kind of a
supplement so that he couldn't be ripped
off before the rest of the book came out
it was a a smart man in a difficult time
and
um
it it's a nice to think I mean I'm not a
scientist uh I am an English major and a
novelist so what are novels about these
are long complicated stories it might
not even be
a major quality of my novelizing that I
like being in the Sierras and attending
to that world I was just reminded of
this an hour ago I walked onto black
speech and back well I spent a lot of my
youth as a as an undergraduate at UCSD
down there at that beach and
um
it sort of forces you to pay attention
and especially being in the water and
swimming and making sure you don't drown
right you talk about almost succumbing
to the tide the currents here yeah yep I
have three near drying events in my uh
childhood and youth one at Corona del
Mar one at Newport Beach and one right
down in Ohio Shores which is a very
simple asset yeah yeah most of the time
I blew it it was a stupid mistake when I
was young and overconfident and I must
say the waves break much further
offshore down here than they do in
Orange County so it was a simple
perceptual error I said oh the waves
aren't very big and when I got out there
they were and I got thrashed maybe the
water was cold whatever I love it and so
of course the interesting thing is can
you put this into sentences where other
people can kind of imagine it mm-hmm so
I can almost grasp you know writing
non-fiction books as I've done now twice
um but the the fictional world it's it's
a mystery to me it seems like such a
different skill set it's like it runs a
jiu jitsu master and one's like a chef
but I know there must be commonalities
between the processes but I wonder can
you talk us through your your what is
your deal you're in it you have a
contract you're working on a new book
it's a fictional book yeah does your
daily routine does it differ from
nonfiction to fiction a and what is it
in any case what is your daily what is
your operating routine there are a lot
of young men who listen to Young Women
too that listen to about what is your
routine to achieve you know to get into
a flow what do you do
well it's been I've only written one
non-fiction book right except for my um
PhD thesis which wasn't a real well it
was but in any case it's always been
fiction and my routine is very simple I
treat it like work I don't wait for
inspiration to strike you can't do that
with novels so I get up at breakfast the
family would go off to school into work
I would be there I would sit down I
would write from after breakfast to
um lunch and then maybe write again in
the afternoon first draft maybe not
um if I was revising I would write it as
long as I was awake and many a day I
would actually after breakfast go out to
the Garden this is very Galileo he did
this too yeah and I would pull weeds and
garden for about an hour get my hands
dirty think things over like what am I
gonna write today and kind of
and Ponder what the scene needed in some
very general sense because it never
comes sharp until you're writing the
sentences themselves and then the scene
actually happens by some strange moment
where I don't want to be mystical about
it but I'm not fully there myself making
decisions it's more like ah yes that it
must have been this way because that's
the only that's a combination of the
most interesting and the most believable
at the same time so let's write that
down and see what it looks like so first
draft and then I go off and I usually
would go for a run or go swim a workout
or go play Frisbee golf do something
athletic because sitting on my butt is
not really my thing despite my job
and then revision as I would say I I can
revise as long as I'm awake and also but
for the afternoons research doing
science fiction especially as an English
major I'd write a scene and then I'd say
to myself if this scene was going to be
really good good I would have to know
more I'd have to know X Y and Z but it
was specific to the scene so my research
was reiterative and supportive and was
expressed in between the first draft and
the subsequent drafts so write a scene
try it out realize what you would need
to know to make it better find that
stuff out try it again and fit in the
new information and a lot of times the
research that I did subsequent to the
first draft would change the story
itself considerably because in the
research I would learn more that that
actually told me you can't even do that
or that's wrong let's it's better to do
it right because it would be more
interesting so it's been a reiterative
process and um well I was taking care of
my kids because now they're grown up now
but when they were young and I was Mr
Mom I would work Monday through Friday
and Saturdays and Sundays I would fool
around with the family and do chores
once they grew up enough I just started
working seven days a week and I got into
streaks like I one time I worked 220
days in a row and it's a streak sort of
like Cal Ripken where occasionally I
would be going to bed and realize I
hadn't ridden that day and I'd write one
paragraph to keep the streak live right
but um it's good for writers to keep a
streak wherever every day you don't get
to decide you're going to write that
date you don't know what you're going to
write but you're going to write
something and that way you have seven
fifths more work done in every week than
if you take your weekends off yeah I
think Stephen pressfield in the war of
art says something like I only write
when I'm inspired but fortunately
inspiration strikes every morning at 9am
well sometimes it doesn't
meaning that he has to put his butt in a
chair yeah exactly clog it a little and
certainly until your butt's in a chair
you're not going to be inspired i i in
the coveted period And since Ministry
for the future is done and and and also
since the High Sierra was done I have
been doing these little poems like
Chinese landscape poems or
um Chinese widows Buddhist dailies
they're very small poems they're more
like diary entries mained into a poem
there I actually wait for inspiration
something happens and I think oh that
would make a good little poem hold on to
that thought so it's completely
different than the physics I can't
resistance I did teach that class the
first ever combination class taught in
Partnership between literature English
literature and physics with our mutual
friend Ray armentrout and winner of the
Pulitzer Prize good old man uh so she is
hopefully listening and Ray I love you I
miss you but we used to debate and I
always put up on the first day of class
I put up this following quote by Dirac
which I'll try to resuscitate the famous
physicist Nobel Laureate came up with
the concept of anti-matter and his
construction of the relativistic theory
of quantum mechanics leading to What's
called the positron and he said uh he
was talking about and he was rumored to
be a very parsimonious with his language
in fact his brother-in-law said
something Paul never uses two words when
none will do
so uh he said the following he said in
physics we tried to express the richness
of the physical Universe in the fewest
possible terms with the small you know
most economical amount of language but
in poetry it's the opposite and Feynman
of course had these ridicules of of the
poet's process he said why is it that
you know if I speak about Jupiter as
being made of methane and and
hydrocarbons and so forth that I'm
somehow less well regarded than you know
Walt Whitman waxing rhapsodically about
the loss of the night's guide to numbers
why is there this you know kind of uh
hostility between the physical sciences
perhaps or the the hard sciences and and
maybe the the humanities you've
perceived that well anything like that I
know what he's talking about and yes it
exists as a thing and somewhat in their
minds on both sides yeah you know it's
the CP snow two cultures Division and
I gotta say Ray armentrout is an example
of a true poet in that she has a gift
and this is a hard thing to describe and
I think it has to do with a sense of
Rhythm because
um as a prose writer I try to be as
precise as a poet as expressive as a
poet but thoughts in Rhythm syllables
that
um between the weak syllables and the
strong syllables and also the end stops
of switching to the next line at a
unexpected moment that nevertheless um
um
makes Bold or prominent one thought or
another or just gives you a little
internal surprise but whatever a poet is
doing
she has a gift for it yeah and I don't
have that gift but I I can I can unders
I can know it when I see it as a reader
right uh and as for the two cultures
split what are you gonna do I'm an
English major from UCSD and Patrick
ledden used to start his non-euclidean
geometry uh classes which I took from
him and loved him with um quotes from
James Joyce he ran the Joyce Workshop
here for a while the seminar on Joyce
and he when he did chalkboards you know
the non-leuclidean the sphere with the
um the hyperbolics and the line yeah the
lines at infinity and where and so he
would draw these perfect circles on the
chalkboard he was making works of art
and quoting Joyce and teaching us
non-euclidean geometry which is pretty
strange stuff
um and interesting in many ways and he
made it quite clear in ways that I now
look back on with some surprise
the split isn't necessary it and I
wonder if it's a little bit of
insecurity on both sides
um in that if you're in the humanities
the world is running under your feet
your life is
um created by the science technology by
the stem science technology engineering
and either math or medicine
um and then on the scientist side you
know they could be they could feel oh my
gosh you know the peoples think that
we're nerds or that we're dry people or
that we only see things as numbers as if
it isn't beautiful when you've got an
equation that works I mean they people
don't understand this and so it's a lack
of understanding on each side but
since I've been a science fiction writer
my whole life I've been trying to say
they are
um shared Enterprises or they're both
equally valuable even though they are
quite different I've been trying to
explain to the humanities Moon science
is actually quite modest in that it
doesn't want to tell people what to do
or what things mean it's how things work
how we might manipulate them
explanations of processes but not
philosophy in the sense of meaning and
not uh ethics and not politics right so
science scientists doing their science
well will be quite they won't claim more
for science than it is attempting to do
right which is to explain things and
once you if you clarify that to people
in the humanities and they get over this
notion that oh scientists have taken
over the world and they and when
actually they haven't they just have
provided an amazingly powerful tools
right so you know you can go on forever
on this uh Science and Arts split but
when you're a science fiction writer and
it's like oh come on you know let's
let's um get over that and talk more
about what we can do together to
illuminate things and go forward yeah
it's like uh the scientist Robert Wilson
I think was one of the
uh original NSF directors or something
in government in the 50s and 60s and
some congressmen asked oh what Mr Wilson
what will this new fangled particle
accelerator do you know for the defense
of the country and and he said well
it'll make it worth defending but I
always invert that and say well it's
really you know the humanities that need
protection and but there also should be
the highest form of expression as you
describe Professor Aladdin we have
lectures named after uh to this day yeah
um you know I think of what is the
purpose of a scholar you know what what
what good do we do and it's it's like
there's a tremendous amount of high bar
that is in my mind what it means to be a
scholar but to have this diversity of
curiosity means you shouldn't just do
physics and you should that's why the
course was called by the way I didn't
tell you this like the course is called
poetry for physicists oh yeah instead of
a physics for poets right so I had
always wanted to do that and one day I
got an email you know I was you get
these emails I'm sure you know our Stan
I'd love to take you out the coffee or
you know pick your brain like I could
get my own coffee thanks very much and
she's writing to me I'd love to take you
out to coffee and I'm in Camp oh by the
way I won the Pulitzer Prize last year
but the undelete you know like oh let me
take this just not a normal person who
asks you out for a cup of coffee and she
had this incredibly discursive curiosity
about cosmology and entanglement she
wrote a poem which won one of the best
poems American poems of 2012 and it's
inspired by me and you can hear it on uh
on Audible and elsewhere just a quick
pause to ask you for a small favor while
my thumb is occupied with old Albert on
it yours is presumably freed up to leave
a thumbs up on this video really helps
me a lot with a good old-fashioned
YouTube algorithm thanks a lot now back
to the video
but when we think about a novel the
thing that's always surprised me
non-fiction you kind of know the story I
mean yes you come in and maybe arrays
you don't exactly know perhaps what
happened before the Big Bang in my case
or something like that but I I know the
story I'm trying to tell uh but with a
novel especially like it's Trilogy or
multi-series multi-part series do you
have to know like someone who's
obviously I'm deeply closeted and I want
to write a novel someday oh tell me Stan
like what do I need what's the
prerequisite how do you know when you
have enough like what what do you what
do you need to go on to start obviously
you can start at any time what do you
what's your theoretical minimum
and the idea itself
um including the resolution like that
yeah well very often yes the resolution
or where I'm headed well the idea itself
um let's see if we can terraform Mars in
200 years that has its resolution at the
end you say yes you don't say no no it's
likely or now but
um uh what if you're like we're not
gonna make it to the stars that this is
a false dream that Humanity's going to
the stars because of biological
constraints and in physics biological so
then oh how would you how would you show
that in a novel well let's do the most
likely thing a multi-generational
Starship and then we'll show the
problems that are unsolvable given the
distances involved and then we'll put
them in a perilous State and actually I
didn't quite know my answer to that one
which is my normal Aurora Ministry for
the future what's the best case scenario
for the next 30 years that you could
still believe in after I described it to
you so um these kind these are ideas the
um some of them are a little crazier
um Galileo when he's looking through his
telescope and he sees the moons of
Jupiter what if he found himself there
like by some kind of matter transfer or
a quantum entanglement and he's standing
on the moons of Jupiter well that's a
pretty crazy notion it's not dissimilar
to a voyage to Arcturus by David Lindsey
a novel from the 20s quite bizarre so
I'm not saying it's a particularly
original idea but once it came to me I
kept pondering and itching at it and I I
have to say that's a strange idea
um I I could go through all of them what
was it like for the people who painted
the Chauvet caves 32 000 years ago
living in the ice age in in the middle
of Europe
what was that like well now that's a
tough speculation and an interesting
thing to try uh man what if sea level
was 50 feet higher and you were living
in Manhattan so these are these are
simply the ideas and then I would pursue
from there have you gotten more or less
optimistic pessimistic about Humanity's
future on mars or interplanetary desires
as Elon says kind of proposed
well interplanetary I'm I'm gung-ho for
the solar system I think um this NASA
slogan space sciences and Earth Science
I totally believe it and I I think a
robust space program is is um very good
for us for for the health of this planet
um the biosphere Health um I love NASA
and I love the space program I love
SpaceX
um not so sure about Elon himself these
days just because of his politics
um which I don't like now but
um
I think it's like Antarctica and so you
know the South Pole base there's gonna
be one of those on Mars and people at
that point they won't care they won't
give a damn it'll be exactly like oh my
God there's people at South Pole right
now how amazing in 95 out of 100 people
you say that to be like well so what no
it's not interesting whereas we know
it's interesting and here's a this comes
from Oliver Morton who's the
environmental editor at um The Economist
and a good writer non-fiction books he
says humans are interested in the place
that we can't quite get to yet
but we hope that we could maybe through
technological achievements or through
courage or through trying repeatedly and
doing stupid things so okay for a long
time is the North Pole then we got there
and indeed Amazon was on his way to the
North Pole when he heard the news that
someone got there and he just told his
crew sorry we're going south flip a yui
we took what a crazy thing that is in
terms of logistics and everything else
but that's what he did and he won so
then the south pole then Everest and
then after that people are kind of at
loose ends and going to the moon was as
shocking but it was interesting the
moment we got to the Moon it wasn't
interesting anymore and so Oliver
speculates and I bet he's right that
when we get to Mars it'll be a nine days
wonder and everybody will freak out the
astronauts will come back home it is not
it should not be a dead-end destiny you
think it's Elon won't die on Mars as
he's reputed to want I mean as Martin
Reed says he'll die in Impact
potentially yeah not on impact but he
might but
um it would be like saying I'm going to
and check into a Motel 6 for the rest of
my life and maybe even a Motel 6
Underground for the rest of my life how
cool is that and it's just not cool you
know I mean even the people who love the
South Pole station or McMurdo yeah they
do not say I'm never coming back I love
this so much the record is about 12
years uh but with a three-month break in
New Zealand exactly traveling about the
south island oh yeah those those
antarcticans they Count Their time down
there by months oh yeah how long you
been in an hour 54 months and you're
thinking that's a little weird to count
it that way but they're taking advantage
of the the coming back and they're proud
of how much time they spent in
Antarctica but they always come back to
the world as they call it
yeah from the ice to the world and
you've been there and we were talking
about the this picture where did I put
that up there uh maybe it's in the frame
maybe it's not yeah it is the dry Valley
so you've been to Antarctica I've spent
only time really at the South Pole and
at McMurdo Station but I greatly prefer
McMurdo because there's more people
there's soft serve ice cream on demand
and you can tell I like that uh but uh
how realistic is it past
um I can't call him a graduate of UCSD
but past attendee of UCSD Andy Weir uh
has been a guest in the podcast uh very
wonderful
um obviously it's a deep connection to
the planet Mars as do you uh he never
graduated but uh he's still welcome to
send his uh donations to UCSC we will
take them Andy as I told you last time
um it was interesting he's very
vulnerable about his time and and uh he
he answered some of the questions about
kind of existential meaning that I'll
get to at the very end of this
conversation a little bit with you
um if you're continue to be as gracious
as I know you are to answer them but he
talked about really the Moon even is
it's not a dead end but in his uh his
novel Artemis after which NASA's new
space program is named no I don't think
it's named after but uh but he claims
the real only economic reason to go to
uh to go to the Moon is for tourist
purposes
are you you know in the same camp when
it comes to the Moon and what about with
Mars exploration I am in the same camp
and I met Andy a couple of times at
science fiction events and enjoyed those
meetings a lot
um
the moon I wrote a moon novel called red
moon it was the one right before
Ministry for the future and I would say
that it's um
the Moon is too small to be interesting
and China is too big to be
comprehensible and putting the two
together I had a novel about Chinese
taking over the South Pole of the Moon
which I think Could Happen
um but nevertheless it was hard to find
a heroic story or any economic reason to
be there but tourism and my addition to
tourism on the moon is I think original
to me and it comes out of Galileo he
noticed that the moon was um shifting a
little bit uh like libation or Library
vibration and he said it was like a man
shaving turning his head back and forth
to see the sides for shaving and so if
you were and even the polls would work
with this and the polls will have water
but along the the two limbs that we see
if you were put into a hotel there
then the Earth would rise and go down on
a like two-week basis it would come over
the horizon it would be up in the low in
the sky and then I'm gonna go back down
again it's almost the only thing you'd
see because everywhere else on the moon
you're going to be seeing the Stars
fixed in position right and people
haven't really thought too much even the
Earth would be fixed in position and
going through its daily cycle of shade
and dark which would be interesting yeah
but to have it come up and down also so
yes the Moon
a dead end and and the so-called
economic reasons are simply I'm going to
say ridiculous the helium-3 the the it's
quantities in astronomy and well
astronomy cool oh no it's it's practical
but it's not an economic driver I mean
look at American astronomers it's an
expense right if you go to the other
side or whatever you want to do it's
like the South Pole itself exactly so if
people say we're going up there in order
to make money you gotta just laugh at
them and I think tourists um there's
probably shouldn't be people Rich enough
to be able to afford to go to the Moon
as a tourist but on the other hand if we
get really
um
um these SpaceX reusable rockets and if
it becomes um not grotesquely expensive
like the people have been going up into
low earth orbit for 20 million dollars I
mean
that's probably a sign they've got too
much money and should be taxed out of it
um so tourism that's not good either now
Mars is different because it's a planet
and once we set up a scientific base
there and astronauts begin to go there
spend a season come back in The
Following Season they'll have taken on a
heavy dose of radiation as you know and
they'll have had the time of their lives
and they'll come back and they'll but
also same at the Moon we don't know what
that low gravity is going to do
I mean we have suspicions it's not good
for you right the microgravity is really
bad for you maybe 37 would be okay maybe
16 maybe we don't know no
um it'll be experiments that astronauts
will be willing to take because it's be
so cool it's a thrill yeah the thrill of
it yeah it might be one of our uh also
illustrious alumni Jessica Maier who is
a graduate of Scripps institutional
geography I'm kind of hoping that she'll
go be the first woman on the moon
because uh I got to interview her twice
once while she was in the ISS floating
above my head wow um let's shift gears
to things that Galileo noted about the
the similarity between the Earth and the
moon those are mountains uh the Sierra
it's a love story and you tell it and
there are characters in it I don't want
to spoil some of the some of this but it
is dedicated to a friend talk about
Terry talk about your your friend who's
uh yeah not with us what a team did you
did you know you knew him from your UCSD
days or I knew him from sixth grade in
up in Orange County we were friends
together close friends from seventh
grade on in sixth grade he was in a
different class and was just a
formidable opponent on the sports Fields
because they played class against class
and then in seventh grade we became good
buddies and we were ever since uh up to
a certain point
um and I want to say parenthetically
that Galilei was so cool in that being
the geometrician that he was that when
he saw there were mountains on the moon
he made a pretty damn good calculation
of how tall they were and it had the
moon sized also right
um impressive as hell that meant but my
friend Terry was also impressive he was
a chemistry major here at UC San Diego
we roomed together our senior year up in
Del Mar and he went up to the Sears with
another UCSD friend Daryl bonan and came
back down and said to me and Joel's who
I just talked to yesterday before
yesterday on his birthday he's out in
Hawaii a Joe and Terry and I went up to
the Sears together under Terry's uh
um
encouragement he said look we got to go
up there it's great let's go to
Desolation it's such a fantastic name it
must be the best place up there and uh
for years for decades this was a pattern
go to the Sears with Terry learn he was
a creative guy he wanted to make gear
lighter he didn't trust the commercial
companies he thought their products were
mostly crap and he was often right he
was way ahead of the curve on ultralight
backpacking and these through hikers
that go from Mexico to Canada in a
single season he was one of those and it
was all his own gear and the industries
the cottage industries that have come up
to serve that community
where they're not just concerned with
ounces but with grams I mean they want a
backpack that weighs five pounds plus
some food yeah one extra bristle on a
toothbrush yeah yeah and he was a he was
like that just out of a personal drive
and he he liked to hike
I'm gonna say he liked to hike 15 and 20
miles a day that's what made him feel
good in the series and he I'm talking
about on trail and I'm the one that kept
insisting let's get off Trail let's go
see places where nobody else goes
because he would have been content to
Trump trails and indeed when this
through hiking came into being he was
fond of it he did it twice but then
he came down with ALS
and uh but Lou Gehrig's disease like
with Stephen Hawking said but many he's
like many people who catch that disease
they're dead within a year
I don't know if there are different
um varieties of it I don't know why once
he won some people can persist first
decades decades and other people they
they measure your hand strength and they
can tell you how many months you have
left and when they found diagnosed him
he had about six months left
this was back in I don't know 2018 or
2019.
so and and I
um you know before that what I've been
reading about ALS is that it can have
mood and cognitive effects before the
physical physical effects show up
whether that's true or not somehow he
got
um
distrustful of uh almost everybody in
his life
so this was a sad thing to see and it
impacted the last decade of his life
pretty Emily and it wasn't a happy time
for him but it's important to remember
that for decades before that he was
a kind of I thought of him as a kind of
a thorough figure I'm out for sure a
mountain Guru he wanted to go up there
he was having fun up there and one time
I saw a walrus
uh at a zoo where you know them on land
and they're just clumping around right
and then if you see them under water
like penguins they're graceful they are
uncontrolled Michael Phelps yeah yeah
exactly well Terry in the Sierras was in
his element and down in in Civilization
he was not in his element he wasn't
comfortable it's just the way it was
with him
I see the eye Sierra as sort of a
different incarnation of Abby's desert
Solitaire in some ways and there's a
phrase that's never left me from that
book which I want to get your reaction
to which is that you know you can't live
on the ocean
um you can't live on the mountains you
fall off or something like that you can
live in the desert and you can kind of
persist there and it's a stable
environment how do you react to that do
you agree with Abby or not no it's such
a Desert Rat
um
um there's a beautiful book by what is
his name it's called the desert by a guy
who had a fever around 1902 and cured it
doctors told him to go out and live in
the desert no I'm sure it's Beaver it's
like Heisenberg's hay fever yeah his
name will come to me but there's only a
few books called the desert and Abby was
like that these Desert Rats they they
love it out there and they you know
maybe they're a bit nocturnal maybe
they're a bit don't like it to be cold
although you can be cold in the desert
as you know
but it isn't um sustainable you would
have to be one of an indigenous person
that really knew that landscape and then
if you're an indigenous person and you
knew that landscape you wouldn't
you'd go to the Owens Valley you'd go
into the rivers you'd be on on the
Cottonwood rivers in the desert you
wouldn't be out there where it was
completely desolated and without water
because you need to live and have both
food and drink that's right now the High
Sierra it's somewhat similar and
somewhat not
um there are summer encampments up there
that the native The Californians went up
to every summer and to boost pass is one
that I write about because I saw it
myself and the reason we know that that
was a summer encampment for hundreds of
years is there are obsidian flakes
everywhere in that Meadow I mean
thousands of obsidian Flakes and so you
can't get there other than these are not
never endemic they were brought by
humans they were chipped off of blocks
and the the chips came from obsidian
Dome so they only carried them I don't
know maybe 20 miles 30 miles and well
obsidian Dome is up near mama so maybe
40 miles but in any case they're there
up in taboo's pass and all over the
Sierra yeah obsidian flakes so a summer
encampa but in the winter you know gonna
be up there you go down to the valleys
below right and so it is livable and
unless you get on the vertical faces
like climbers do it's not particularly
dangerous but
um I must say I've often thought about
this food up there they were probably a
killing deer with snares or with arrows
and they were probably pulling Meadow
onions and also they had such a good
supply of acorns and pine nuts and and
carry up a backpack full of uh pine nuts
ready to eat or acorns that had already
been leached grounded yeah exactly so um
it was pretty robust but not the actual
Local Food Supplies once you get up a
baba out
say 8 000 feet is relatively minimum
um so a main character in the book is
John Muir and I'm proud to say I am a
member of Muir College we have this
college system here at UCSD as you know
and other may not know but John Muir is
one of them now he has complicated
Legacy you and I talked about this in
Washington DC when we were there I
should also mention that you're gracious
enough to participate in events for the
RFC Clark Center for human imagination
which I'm honored to be the associate
director of I'm with Eric veery
um Patrick Coleman Stuart Volcan and
others uh but you have um you and I just
chat in the car uh on your way uh our
both Mutual Way to the Amtrak station
after Michio Kaku and others won the uh
and you spoke as well at the Clark
Foundation awards that was fun couple
years ago
um and that was a great time but you and
I talked about Muir and sort of some of
the complicated aspects of his of his
life and and his career I love the
portrayal I love the quotes that you use
you do talk about it in the book famous
one of course I found by going out I was
really going in yeah um what does Mira
mean to you and what do you say to those
who says his legacy has been tarnished
and compromised in some sense yeah well
I conceive of myself as a his defense
attorney because that is a this that is
a calumny he has been mischaracterized
um and this was a kind of a click bait
gotcha moment a canceled culture moment
of 2020
um of the executive director of the
Sierra Club cravenly gave into it and
supported it she found it or almost he
he didn't find you mentioned the book
yeah he well he certainly was well
involved but there were men mostly men
in San Francisco who came to him and
said well you'll help us start a Sierra
Club and he said hell yeah
um and the leader in 2020 yeah so so
this is a moment that has passed I was
extremely angry in 2020 because
um the people who were accusing him of
racism they had not read him and I've
read him and I mean in full even to the
point of going to his archives at
University of Pacific in Stockton
California and reading all the
unpublished stuff I needed to be sure
right like um to prove a negative is
difficult as you know and this is one of
the scientists big problem so if I say
no he was not a racist well how do you
prove a and one way to try is to
read everything yeah and I have to say
there's a dozen sentences of him of his
that are obnoxious
um that are a little ignorant on his
part and a little judgy
um he was Presbyterian his dad whipped
him through his Youth and childhood he
was kind of PTSD he didn't like seeing
people sitting around during the daytime
and he didn't like people with dirty
clothing at both of those things he
found shocking and sinful
not that he stayed a Christian but he
had these attitudes beaten into him
um but aside from about a dozen
sentences his admiration for Native
Californians and Native Americans in
general was strong and he never had much
of anything to say about the recently
freed slaves of the South when he was a
kid he hiked all the way down to Florida
and saw the shattered South and he made
relatively objective sometimes admiring
admiring comments sometimes critical
comments sometimes ignorant comments
about the black people he met in the
South but once he got to California he
had very little contact with them at all
so if you hunt for these sentences the
new executive director of the Sierra
Club Ben jealous whose previous job was
at the NAACP right Benjo said once
recently you know mirror sometimes he
sounds like a guy writing in the 19th
century
and I think that's so well put
um and there are some sentences that are
19th century sentences that we wouldn't
say now right it fell into the 20th
century unfortunately but right it is
plucked out of the record oh what a bad
man but I want to finish the point by
saying what did Mir actually do yeah
because Audubon had slaves and even uh
krober
um Ursula Gwen's father
um he had his name taken off of
buildings in Berkeley because he had
ishi's brain sent to the Smithsonian and
because he told the federal government
that some of the Native Californians
around the San Francisco Bay did not
constitute tribes and that kept them
from getting Federal listings and so
their lives were impacted by Kroger's
opinions Muir never did any of that and
the main accusation against mirror as to
doing stuff was that he encouraged the
national park system to kick Native
Americans off their land in order to
make a pure Wilderness that never
happened that absolutely did not happen
he died before the National Park Service
right was established but also he never
said that to anybody not to Teddy
Roosevelt not to anybody he I mean when
he said everybody should go up to the
mountains and get their Glad Tidings he
was thinking of his white middle-class
audience that were in the cities but he
was certainly never said they should get
these native Californians out of here to
make a better Wilderness Area that is
simply a lie and now that I've read all
of him and seen the context he actually
said once these native Californians they
live so well in the landscape right they
made them yeah yeah he did and he said
also it's clear that they burned this
valley floor in order to clear it for to
make Parkland out of it so this people
who accused him of not even knowing the
ecological fire management practices
they're wrong about that too right so to
I mean I don't want to go on too long
about this but mirror a heroic figure
the world's most famous Environmental
list and he still is worth valuing
because the Sierras are the way they are
because he was such a good writer too
like Galileo he could capture the Beauty
and the sacredness of the Outdoor World
right he's eminently uh eminently
quotable as well yeah
um so I want to ask a couple final
questions and wrap up with my
existential you used to call it the
thrilling three now I call it the final
four we'll see how many we can get to I
know you've got a huge event coming up
and not too long from now
um first though I want to pitch an idea
to you uh my nascent entry into science
fiction so Kim pray there is a National
Academy member Professor atmospheric
chemistry she's closely associated with
the idea of atmospheric Rivers which you
talk about in your book is Pineapple
Express is what it used to be Brandon
now now it's kind of Revisited but one
of her theories and sorry Kim if you're
listening another Kim uh famous Kim acsd
Associated last night
um so one of our theories is that
microbes May control the generation and
diminution of the atmospheric River
phenomena when there's a drought that
they do nuclear and they do cause this
upwelling and so forth that they enter
into the atmosphere providing nucleation
sites for precipitation to fall which
then cures the drought right so here's
my pitch to you you're the uh you're the
book agent right okay
um
can we turn this into a science fiction
novel or the microbes are taking over
the planet maybe add in some Paul Davies
a little Shadow biosphere because
they're not from Earth perhaps but they
want to maintain the Earth so that we
can get to planet borkon and then save
anyway what do you think yay or nay
through the Caligula do the thumbs up
though holy moly go for it all right go
for it um I I don't start it here first
yes I you need to figure out the plot
and uh here's what I say a plot is
something goes wrong that's really the
quick definition of a plot and you don't
want to read a novel that doesn't have a
plot that's I I've had my my butt
whipped for trying that
um and it doesn't work so uh what I love
about this is I'm right now reading the
correspondence between James Lovelock
and and Lynn margulis and it's a funny
and interesting
um dialogue between the two of them as
they work out this homeostasis or this
cybernetic feedback loops and she's the
Biola and he's the cyberneticist and
all-around space cadet super scientist
he's lower Buck was really good although
erratic and strange an independent
scholar and but he he they didn't want
to make it um Mother Earth they didn't
want a personification they wanted a
name for a
it was it's actually somewhat hard to
describe what guy is with some kind of
supra organism that is self a not well
see all that yeah it's all personified
that right yeah yeah but homeostatic is
a good way to put it into just um
cybernetic terms um but with living
elements in it that want to live and are
encouraged by living so what I love
about this idea is
um I just think Lovelock and margulis
would love it yeah interesting yeah all
right well it gets at least a
provisional stamp of approval all right
Stan we've reached the sort of end where
we transition into questions of
existential import and all of these in
some way or another are tangentially or
directly related to quotes of the great
Arthur C Clarke did you meet Arthur by
phone only okay yeah but he had a deep
influence on you and passed an upcoming
guest Peter diamandis who also sends
regards and oh yeah he's a great friend
of the Clark Center as well um so Clark
would say many things so one of my
favorite that I love to drop on my
faculty colleagues at a faculty meeting
is for every expert there's an equal and
opposite expert I love to drop that on
my department chair from time to time
um but I also said uh that any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable for magic and if you
are a subscriber to my mailing list I
call it the magic mailing list because
we go through different aspects of what
Clark and memories and and and and sort
of imaginative Concepts but
I want to reimagine that question and
say what aspect of humanity is most
magical to you what what invention what
would you put on an on an obelisk on a
monolith you know that could be a time
capsule a sentinel for last for billions
of years to give us the Swagger that we
might deserve to say we were here what
would you put on such a such a
Talisman or you know future Shard of our
existence what should Humanity be most
proud of in your conception I'm most
proud of oh my God I don't know I mean
anesthetics
um
um heart surgery
um medicine in general I think science
came out of an urge to reduce our
suffering
and and make us more comfortable in the
world less hungry less hurt than how to
do that trial and error
um a lot of early scientists were women
the herb woman
um as in my novel Shaman so I would say
medicine right off the bat because now
we're living like I'm living
um Extended lifetime lies in my Mars
novels I just hit 71 but I it's only
medicine that I got past about 65.
um I bet I've had my life saved twice by
medicine so I'm particularly sensitive
to how lucky we are to have the
scientific project with that as its high
point now I would also say I'm you
talked about Paul Davies a wonderful
writer and thinker my God he's the only
person that ever has been able to
explain some of the details of quantum
mechanics in a way that I followed him
and that's mostly metaphorical and
writing ability not mathematical in
terms of his ability to explain to a
layperson he's fabulous and a good guy
and he writes about mysticism a lot and
so this is also appeared till hard to
Chardon you got the lithosphere the
atmosphere you got the biosphere and
then the new duosphere which is the
chardon's word for the mental maybe the
thoughts of Gaia The Anthem yeah exactly
and it is a human the neurosphere is
created by human thinking so even the
internet as a technological
manifestation of the neurosphere or I
said once in my Mars books that first
Mars has a new sphere and then it got an
atmosphere in a biosphere because we
thought of it first and then did it then
we instantiated it yeah here it's the
reverse on earth right so that was what
I would say medicine for sure okay
another quote from Sir Arthur
um when an elderly but distinguished
scientist says something is possible he
is most certainly right when he says
something is impossible he is very
likely wrong as you stand what if you
change your mind on what if anything
have you been wrong about what would you
like a mulligan about if anything
whatsoever
I'm not calling you elderly by the way
yeah no I would um like to take all
mentions of blockchain out of Ministry
for the future I think it was impressive
yeah I think blockchain is bad coding
and will be
um a phenomenon of just this decade and
there will be better coding systems
later so but that's a trivial thing yeah
um
I I
that's a good question I don't know I I
was at UCSD 50 years ago I was an
undergrad I was
several things converged in my brain at
once and made me who I am and ever since
then I've been kind of
um bowling along like a bowling ball
enjoying life and seeing the world
um
I
I can't think of
things that have
um caused me to change anything major in
my thinking since then but now this is
probably an admission of my my thinking
has been too fixed not that flexible I'm
a creature of habit and so my habits
have been fixed for a long time well
that's Yogi Bear said if it ain't broke
yeah well I should never I should not
have spent so many years indoors that's
an accident especially as a Californians
um you can spend
um 50 to 100 percent more time than you
do outdoors just by deciding to and I
didn't make that decision until you know
about 2006 or so do you mind having more
skin you know you've got well remarkably
smooth uh I've got a bunch of skin
cancers chopped out of me even still oh
wow oh hell yeah all right last question
can Stan and I'll let you on your way
um and that's the uh the following
statement by Sir Arthur that the only
way of determining the limits of the
possible is to venture Beyond them into
the impossible that's how we get the
name of this podcast after all yeah
gonna ask you
um what advice to 21 year old Stan here
at UCSD what advice would you give to
yourself to give yourself the courage to
do as you've done to go into the
impossible advice to your former self
well can I say as an English major and a
word person that this is not a good use
of language that if you say impossible
you mean impossible and so and Clark was
bad at this too but Hughes came from
physics
um there's not going to be faster than
light travel by human beings I just say
that it's impossible and you can come
back in 500 years and we'll test that
out and I'll still be right then but
this is one thing that physics is very
good at you know although you know we do
have dark matter we it's not like we
understand everything things are quite
mysterious right now but some things I
think are impossible
so um and also this whole notion say
that okay Humanity like is destined for
the stars and if we don't make it to the
Stars we must have been idiots as a
species we must have failed but if you
set yourself an impossible goal and then
you fail then you've just some the goal
was stupid or it could be like you know
so it says oh I'm superior to you Stan
because I have a nicer phone than you
you know who's the most powerful people
on Earth they don't even have phones
someone else has a phone for them right
yeah yeah so it's a false dichotomy it
is indeed and and these the use of
language we have all these words that
are um getting squished out of their
natural element and being overused and
pressured to the point where they blow
up like a balloon that you've stopped so
that um you know the word artificial
intelligence what if the name what if
you just said uh extremely rapid
computation or Freedom what if you
change that to God knows what or people
say oh he's very unique and you've got
to understand that unique cannot take
adjectives so you get into English major
um Harrison right about words
um I would say if you put a tears of
yourself if going back you're teleported
through their quantum mechanical
wormholes gone back stands here what do
you say to him
don't worry too much about making
mistakes the mistakes will lead to later
developments that are so cool that this
play of title of Shakespeare's all's
well that ends well if it ends well then
the crap along the way was necessary so
don't don't fret about mistakes I often
did that
those mistakes actually led me into the
life I'm in
so and I think maybe you know it's got
to be a time of anxiety climate anxiety
um anxiety about jobs and careers in a
world in flux and a gig economy and
everything's changing and people who are
20 years old a day they're 50 years
coming for them is going to be wild be
easy to be anxious well you just gotta
ride the wave and and you know all's
well it ends well
very well from one great Wordsmith to
another it's Dan thank you so much for
being so gracious with your time your
effort your support of the Clark Center
and everything you do for UCSD and San
Diego and the World At Large for the
Sierras which I know you love thank you
for writing this love letter to them and
uh and your many Works along the way
thank you so much well thank you Brian
it's a real pleasure you know me I love
UCSD I love mirror College I love the
Clark Center I loved Clark and so we are
right on the same Vibe with all this
stuff fantastic yeah thank you all
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
[Music]